this is the story of five fearless
superheroes 2020 more TV superheroes
just what the world needs there
somewhere know you but appearances boy
are we really the best people to hunt a
super villain Oh No
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie Justice
League twenty20 we have to break down
this Doom Patrol trailer and I'll
explain what's going on with the Justice
League in the Titans Doom Patrol
universe because those two shows are
connected and we've already had cameos
from some big Justice League members and
references well explain which people we
know about in terms of those big AILA's
characters and who they're saving for
later seasons because we actually just
got confirmation that Warner Brothers
made a really big change in the way that
it treats the a-list big Justice League
characters in the TV universes and that
includes the CW DC TV universe in the DC
Universe is what they're calling the
streaming service universe of the Titans
Doom Patrol all those TV shows will do a
new round of that DC Universe giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Titans moment on the video big thing
here they just want to give you a
rundown to some of the characters they
gave you a very first look at Alan Tudyk
smiston Oh buddy character from the
grant Morrison Doom Patrol run I'll try
to say as much as I can about him and
the other characters because I have seen
the first two episodes but I'm under
embargo till next week to talk about the
episodes in really great detail so if it
wasn't clear Alan Tudyk is the main
villain he's playing mr. nobody he's the
character that exists between dimensions
so he has a lot of really crazy reality
warping powers during his voiceover
during the trailer he spends a lot of
time making fun of the Doom Patrol what
does the world need a whole bunch of
more superhero just calling them a bunch
of freaks people that nobody cares about
and he makes a lot of jokes about people
not liking the show so Alan Tudyk is
probably one of the best things about
the Doom Patrol series once you get a
chance to see episode 1 you'll hear what
I'm talking about because he sort of
operates as the omniscient narrator for
the episodes but he's also a character
in the series so he spends a lot of time
breaking the fourth wall Deadpool style
just cracking jokes about the show in
general the DC Universe the Titans TV
show and all the stuff that's going on
in real life so it gets really meta if
you've ever read a Grant Morrison comic
book they are psychedelic trippy weird
acid trips of stories the TV show isn't
too dense or anything like that but it
does try to take inspiration from a lot
of Grant Morrison's sense of creativity
in the way that he wrote the characters
who just do a quick rundown of the
footage then I'll talk about TV Justice
League because I mean the big thing here
is is the air over
has not quite gotten to Justice League
yet effectively they're there but they
haven't said the words or anything like
that they actually canonized the Justice
League on Titan so that means the Titans
in the DC Universe streaming service
universe of shows beat them to it but
the Doom Patrol episodes continue on
that idea and they broaden the Justice
League you learn about more characters
that are alive and well in existing
members of the team during the course of
events on the show but the big
difference between Doom Patrol
and a show like Titans or even the CW
arrowverse TV shows is that they're
meant to be ultra misfits versus the
ultra weird of the DC Universe so all
the characters that you see them do all
the storylines will feel way weirder
than anything that you would see on the
DC TV shows and that includes legends of
tomorrow which sort of prides itself on
being the weirdest of the DC TV shows so
even though this footage is meant to
intro the entire team but it starts off
focusing on a lot of crazy Jayne footage
just because her powers are so cool
amongst the other team members she's
also a standout character in the first
few episodes visually and in terms of
her performance because she has 64
different distinct personalities each
one has a different superpower so you
start off with this shot of negative man
inside a special machine that's a
metahuman gene accelerator device they
explained that in the first episode so I
don't want to give too much of that away
but this is a device that helps activate
people's powers there's a shot of crazy
Jayne in one of her firebase
personalities chasing robot man down the
hallway inside the doom patrols mansion
so she's actually flying through the air
on fire because one of her personalities
has that ability then there's a shot of
crazy Jayne with one of her other
personalities that has electrical-based
powers so within the first couple of
episodes you do get a sense for a number
of different personalities and what
their powers are and they give you
easter eggs for a lot of the other 64
but because there's only gonna be about
ten episodes I don't think that there's
any way we're gonna see every single one
of her different personalities they'll
probably save a lot of that for future
seasons if they get renewed for season
two you get a shot of robot man
destroying two henchmen notice the
difference here between this shot in the
way the arrowverse treats scenes like
this you see them hit the wall and you
see bloodstains so just a reminder that
this is a streaming network show it's
not regulated by the FCC it's
same thing with the Netflix series they
can be as graphic as they want to so
they do take advantage of that during
the first couple of episodes there's
that robot man's Justice League twenty20
joke one that's a reference to them
becoming the next Justice League like
haha yeah like we would ever be the next
Justice League but it also serves to
remind you that the Justice League
really does exist in the Titans Doom
Patrol DC Universe the first genuine
live-action TV justice league in years
you get the rundown of negative man he
has an energy form the way that they
explain it on the TV show is that it's
an energy based alien life form that
fuses with him and they're treating the
energy form as a wholly different
consciousness from negative man so like
they actually do try to communicate with
each other in the first couple of
episodes you remember a lot of these
characters from that Titans episode so
not a whole lot has changed between that
episode and what's going on in the
series but I will explain the timeline
crazy Jane like I said one of the best
characters on the show so far cyborg is
a really interesting character - the way
they treat him they've made a couple
minor changes to his backstory in how he
became cyborg but he's one of those
characters where they don't completely
give you everything about his origin
right away like he slowly uncovers a lot
of false memories so I'm expecting a
couple twists with his backstory that
we'll learn about later in the season
overall his performance so far I think
is pretty decent I'll talk a little more
about him when the embargo is up next
week and I can get into a little more
detail about what's going on during the
episodes Brendan Fraser's robot man
brings a lot of the comedy to the series
and just a reminder too that it's not
brendan fraiser underneath the robot
costumes they have like a different
super tall actor walking around because
he's meant to be like eight feet tall
and Brendan Fraser just does the voice
they recast the chief and now it's
Timothy Dalton I can't talk too much
about him without getting into spoilers
so we'll save that for later but Timothy
Dalton is fantastic you all know that so
no big surprise there that he does a
really cool version of the character the
versions of the episodes that I saw were
just temps like they didn't have
finished special effects but they look
actually pretty good in terms of special
effects so I don't know if they gave
them more money to produce these
episodes than they gave on Titans but TV
Justice League so here is the current
status of the Justice League
within Titans in the Doom Patrol
universe we know about Batman he's alive
in an active member
thanks to trigons mind control at the
end of titan season 1 but Batman in
reality is alive and well within the
Titans universe andis an active member
of the Justice League we know thanks to
Donna Troy that Wonder Woman is alive
and well
also still an active member in the
Justice League Superman is also alive
and well and an active member I think
they're waiting to show him on screen
until we actually get a legitimate
episode with connor ken and we only got
that teaser at the end of titan season 1
[Music]
me
what'll probably happen is is once they
start to learn who Connor is what his
backstory is then we'll get a little bit
more from Clark Kent Superman within
this universe but keep in mind that it
will not be Tyler hoechlin if they do a
version of Superman they'll just recast
a different actor because as of the tcas
they have now confirmed that these are
all different universes
so the movies are their own universe The
CW DC TV shows are their own universe in
the live-action shows on the DC Universe
like Titans Doom Patrol that's their own
universe as well too so that is why you
have multiple versions of characters
showing up on all these different places
so this will blow your mind
I just posted a video for the recent
flash episode there is a Barry Allen
flash inside the Titans Doom Patrol
universe we haven't seen him on screen
yet but it is definitely not Grant
Gustin
or Ezra Miller it'll be a wholly
different character that I think they'll
also probably save until they do a
version of say like Bart Allen or
another speedster on the team the only
other really big a-list characters that
have not been mentioned yet or say like
Aquaman and because he's so big of
course they're probably gonna do some
Aquaman stuff on Titans eventually but
they'll probably wait until they try to
do Aqualad or another related character
then they'll start talking more about
Aquaman because that's kind of how they
dealt with Batman and Wonder Woman in
Superman like the kind of waited until
they introduced those other associated
characters like Robin and Donna Troy
so beyond that anything is game they
haven't said anything about Black Canary
or Green Arrow inside that universe the
Hawks Hawkman Hawkgirl Martian Manhunter
or like Hal Jordan Green Lantern but I
think we'll all get there eventually
within the Titans DC Universe let me
know in the comments what do you think
of Doom Patrol so far and let me know
who you want to play that new
live-action version of Superman
inside the Titans DC Universe let me
know if there's any special DC videos
that you guys want me to make I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post a new DC
video but click here for my brand new
Avengers endgame and Captain Marvel
trailer video and click here to watch
Wally West come back during Young
Justice season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight